I feel like if I was a liberal who was
running I wouldn't want Biden to come
down to campaign with me because Biden's
been so bad he's been such a failure I
think most people not just in Florida
but all over the country are probably
like oh my gosh everything was great
under Trump and now everything's
horrible under Biden so if I was a
Democrat running I would say here's what
I'm going to do different maybe from
both maybe this is like a new idea have
a new plan don't associate yourself with
Biden just do your separate campaigns
you're right there have been many
Democrats who have told them do not send
Joe Biden here like we can maybe win if
he doesn't show up and then he shows it
to Miami and look what happens a day
later Republicans overtake Democrats I
got I gotta say I'm willing to bet
people went out saw him and then went no
way not happening and then immediately
went we're like I'm voting Republican
were there poll numbers before his
speech or yeah I mean these are early
vote numbers that's what ABC is
reporting before he came Democrats were
leading